[Música]
o tom que junta mais um vídeo e hoje vou
mostrar os desvios que o myspace fazer
no ano passado ou seja vocês vão ver que
agora uma contração de 10 vídeos para
uma mulher bem rápido e em poucos a
vocês vão vir a calhar vocês vão gostar
de alguma coisa e isso quiserem fazer
alguns limites territoriais não está na
divisão pela mesma hora em que vocês vão
ver nesta compilação e nos comentários
qual fui o projeto vocês mais gostaram
desse ano passado poucos por vezes
porque sabia que vocês gostam mais
então eu posso fazer mais do gênero e
quero nem estou pronto vamos contar
[Música]
assim
a lei
[Música]
essa
ae
[Música]
o
i
ae
[Música]
livre
o
o o ó
[Música]
dantas
eu vou com um
[Música]
é
o
[Música]
o número
e provoca bloqueio espero que vocês
tenham gostado visto a gente agora
estava destruindo os resultados num
único ano em que jogou com o salamanca
escolhido o melhor filme português então
vocês quiserem votar nestes prémios o
link está na condição de espírito e
estou pronto muito obrigado até a brasil
cacau